Donald Trump is quickly turning into
what I am referring to as orange Bill
Cosby or if you prefer Bill Cosby to
point Oh numerous women now coming out
and saying Donald Trump the Republican
presidential candidate inappropriately
touch them some of these allegations
involve teens the situation is getting
to be absolutely insane and Trump's
campaign is imploding let's start of
course you might remember over the
weekend the leaked audio of Donald Trump
speaking to Billy Bush in 2005 expose
Donald Trump talking very loudly about
what he does to women including kissing
them or touching them no matter what it
is that they want also referring to
grabbing women's genitals now we realize
that what Trump said during that second
presidential debate these are just words
well its words indicative of actions
that Donald Trump has apparently taken
multiple times Donald Trump said I've
not done anything wrong these are just
words but now the stories of Donald
Trump inappropriately touching women
have started to pour in we will start
with the New York Times report
summarizing some of them we will start
with Jessica leads now 74 years old
reporting that more than three decades
ago when she was traveling as a
businesswoman for a paper company she
sat next to trump on an airplane in the
first-class cabin to New York they had
never met before shortly after takeoff
Trump lifted the armrest and started
touching her grabbing her breasts trying
to put his hand up ms Lee's skirt he was
like an octopus is the way that she
described the incident she went to the
back of the plane and sees this as an
assault she mentioned this to a friend
who confirmed the story to the New York
Times and said this is exactly as she
told me about this decades ago Rachel
crooks was at one point a 22 year old
receptionist at bay rock group was a
that's a real estate investment firm in
Trump Tower encounter Donald Trump in an
elevator in 2005 she knew that Trump did
business with the her company she turned
trip to introduce herself to trump they
shook hands
and then Trump wouldn't let go instead
starting to forcefully kiss her and then
directly kissing her on the mouth moving
from the cheeks to the mouth she said
this was no accident it was a violation
she called her sister at the time at the
who also spoke to the New York Times and
confirmed the story now here's my
favorite part the really insane
revealing part of the New York Times
story yesterday about the sexual assault
claims against the Republican nominee
Donald Trump is how Trump reacted to the
new york times asking him about it
here's a transcript of this piece of the
conversation from the New York Times
article which says in a phone interview
on tuesday night a highly agitated mr.
Trump denied every one of the women's
claims none of this ever took place said
mr. Trump who began shouting at the
Times reporter who was questioning him
he said that the times was making up the
allegations to hurt him and that he
would sue the news organization if it
reported them you are a disgusting human
being he told the reporter as she
questioned him about the women's claims
this is how he reacts Trump can't even
handle questions from a newspaper about
alleged sexual assaults how would he be
able to handle anything about being
president of the United States but it's
not just these two women in People
magazine Natasha stone off said that she
and Trump walked into a room alone Trump
shut the door behind them she turned
around and within seconds Trump was
pushing her against the wall and forcing
his tongue down her throat and then of
course we have the story of Mindy
mcgilvery uh or maybe it's Browns
MacGillivray in the palm beach post who
said that back in 2003 Trump grabbed her
rear the Trump campaign has not yet
responded to the story but it's not just
these four women either there are four
women who competed in the 1997 miss teen
USA beauty pageant who said Donald Trump
just came into the dressing room while
we were changing there were 15 year-old
girls in there naked and Trump just
walks in women given note
I'm at all to cover up nothing announced
ahead of time numerous women including
miss vermont Teen USA Mariah bilodeau
saying I turn around and there's a man
in there and I'm not wearing any clothes
this is what Trump has bragged about
doing Pat I mean there is just no
mystery here Trump has bragged about
this and now the stories are pouring in
there's no inconsistency and of course
it's an issue of great public interest
yeah all of these women are coming
forward with about a month left in the
election and really there's no reason to
give Trump the benefit of the doubt
given the comments that he said no note
if anything Trump's comments tell us Oh
yet that this is just people
corroborating what Trump said that he
does and remember his campaign manager
Kellyanne Conway said all women deserve
to be heard in regards to sexual
misconduct allegations well we're
hearing them now and I hope Kellyanne
Conway supports that and remember Donald
Trump once said nobody has more respect
for women than I do fortunately that's
not true Hillary Clinton should leave
this alone Trump is imploding on his own
Hillary Clinton does not need to get
involved in this just keep showing up
keep answering the questions including
at the last third and final presidential
debate next week Trump is imploding down
by double digits in multiple national
polls at this time